when I talk to students today or public
groups about immigration law often in
people's mind is a concern about illegal
immigration and some of the lobbying
work going on in America is the phrase
what is it about illegal you don't
understand so that's an invitation to me
as someone who knows law to stop and say
well the opposite of illegal is legal so
let's lay the table let's let's describe
the categories that our current law
welcomes as legal immigrants and give
people some idea of the numbers all
right I want everyone to imagine for a
minute that there's a big big pie and
that pie right now is the United States
populated with should we use the number
of 350 million people of the 350 million
between young people and retired people
we have maybe a hundred and fifty
million people actually working so we
have an economic pool of 350 million
consumers and residents and citizens who
have been a hundred and fifty million
people working so if I asked you then
how many people does Congress authorize
to permanently immigrated to United
States to to enter the United States and
obtain what we call a green card the
vernacular name the nickname for
permanent residency you might say well
let's see 350 million people maybe 3.5
million that seems like a small percent
that'd be one percent of our total
population the actual number is we
authorized around 1 million immigrants
every year
the bureaucracies that control
immigration let's just list them all
right there's the Department of State
that issues visas overseas and conducts
some of the security clearances and has
to make determinations on eligibility
for both temporary and permanent visas
there is the Department of Homeland
Security a newly created cabinet level
office created in 2002 in part a
response to the attacks of 9/11 that one
agency houses within it the US
Citizenship and Immigration Service the
Customs and Border Protection the
immigration Customs Enforcement
those three agencies obviously have
immigration but there's also Department
of Health Services Department of Labor
sometimes those agencies have to do
preclearance certificates so that
someone can also enter the United States
so we have literally hundreds of
thousands of federal employees whose
main job is to administer our
immigration laws and we've increased it
dramatically in the Bush administration
partially as a tool of national security
a concern about attacks that occurred on
9/11 and partially a concern by many
people in the United States that we have
too many people coming over our southern
border and that we need to increase our
Border Patrol and the office of
immigration customs enforcement that's
one layer we also have a huge amount of
our Department of Justice resources
going to immigration cases there are
about 300,000 deportation cases in the
immigration courts that's an
Administrative Tribunal within the
Department of Justice we have
prosecution of immigration crimes the
fastest-growing category of federal
crime in other words if you looked at
all the federal crime prosecutions which
category grows the most quickly is it
drug possession is it smuggling of
illegal cigarettes no it's immigration
crimes particularly in the southern
border but also here in New York on the
upper border with Canada it is the US
Attorneys offices around the country are
prosecuting people for illegal reentry
after an order
removal so we have a lot of resources in
all those agencies the cost to our
economy is that family members
businesses that want to bring immigrants
to the United States need experts to
jump through the hoops and hurdles they
hire immigration attorneys the American
Immigration Lawyers Association has a
current membership of nearly 15,000
lawyers in the United States that's in
contrast to when I entered the field in
1983 where there were fewer than 800
members
we do have no formal quota for anyone
marrying a US citizen so therefore you
get movies like Sandra Bullock's latest
film the proposal where I understand I
haven't seen the film but she's supposed
to be a Canadian executive who needs to
get a green card right away so she
marries her assistant and I throw up my
hands and say but there were five other
ways for her to immigrate marriage is a
method of immigrating to United States
if you marry United States citizen where
there's no immediate quota it doesn't
always mean it's rabid if you were a US
servicemen and you met a woman in
Afghanistan and you wanted to marry her
there doing the paperwork processing the
security clearances going through the
health checks it may be anywhere from
let's say six months shortest period I
can imagine to several years delay just
because of the hoops and hurdles we put
people through to immigrate but as a
matter of principle and as table setter
yes our country's very generous in that
u.s. citizens may bring their spouses
right away copy of course because of the
Defense of Marriage Act Congress has
said federal law will only recognize
marriage between a man and a woman so
the same sex marriages even if legal
under them all of their nation or would
be legal in a particular state in the
United States that now recognizes
same-sex marriage cannot be a basis for
sponsoring an immigrant spouse and
that's certainly an area of controversy
some of our illegal immigration problem
is that people who love each other who
have the closest relationship in the
world of spouse who want to bring their
spouse legally are facing these enormous
lengthy delays Congress has only
recently ameliorated it a little bit by
allowing some people who were caught in
bureaucratic delays to at least come
temporarily to live with their spouse
but there's no general provision that
says you may wait out the quota in the
United States so I just want people
watching this or listening to this to
think if you were in love
remember those that blush of the first
romance and how you couldn't wait so
your boyfriend got out of algebra class
let alone wait 12 years to live together
with your spouse it's an incentive for
people to enter the country
surreptitiously or to overstay on a
tourist visa or some other temporary
visa so part of our what is it about
illegally don't understand is there are
people whose heart and soul is now
situated in this country but the legal
system delay is just so long